hello i'm very thrilled to have a
conversation with costume designer
ariane phillips who
is an academy member and a three-time
oscar nominee
for her work on walk the line w e and
once upon a time in hollywood
today we're going to talk about her work
specifically on hedwig and the angry
inch so
ariane thanks very much for joining us
um
i i'm thrilled to have you here first
thing i want to do is thank you
for the items that you've donated to the
academies library
and museum would you like to talk a
little bit about what some of those
things were
sure thank you randy for having me in
anticipation of the opening of the
museum i am
so excited to be part of anything and
everything uh
you know ampus museum so i really
appreciate being here
and being able to talk about one of the
most important films
in my personal trajectory as a costume
designer
hedwig is i would say probably at the
center point
of uh the most meaningful one of the
most
meaningful and uh sustainably creative
experiences that
that uh keeps on going as you know the
appreciation
and the love for hedwig 20 years later
is not lost on me so
thrilled to talk about it and yes yes um
you know for many years i've been
donating my sketches and visual
materials to the margaret herrick
library
with wonderful ann coco over there and
it's just been
such a wonderful asset to be able to
have a place where the work can live on
and be there if anybody's interested in
looking at it and it can be taken care
of and looked after and of course
in in the vault of history of our own
history as filmmakers so
my journey in terms of donations uh
really started
with uh that relationship with ann coco
um and over the years i've donated many
sketches uh
some of which are hedwig sketches and
then when i got
news that the museum would be collecting
specific pieces costume pieces for their
archive
i think there was a ripple of excitement
through our community
and me especially because of all the
films that i've designed
hedwig happens to be the only film in
which i own the costumes which was part
of my
initial deal that i made with the
producers
given that it was a small indie film
um and uh you know it was kind of to
offset
the lack of compensation i said well
okay i'll keep the costumes and
you know i've been holding on to them
and um
you know here and there people will come
over to my studio and look at them
and and get so much joy you know you
never know when you're working on a film
how it will resonate with the audience
and hedwig is just such a special
movie and that generationally people
are responding to it and it's become
kind of a classic
in its own kind of outsider way so
i guess it was very fortunate of me to
be able to make that deal with the
producers that i could
keep the costumes and now have the
opportunity
to donate them to the museum so that
future generations and our community if
people are interested in can see them
and someday maybe they'll make it on
exhibition and the thing about paper
materials
and textiles costumes is that they
can deteriorate over time lose their
luster
their color the quality
so knowing that these costumes are being
preserved
um under the curation of the museum is
just
thrilling fantastic thank you so much
for that and
uh i just want to say that these
costumes even though they happen to be
the only
uh set you have from your work it's a
great set to have because they are such
iconic images and i think
they also are just fun there's a lot of
times when you watch a film
and the costumes feel like they're just
part of the
natural story and you're not really
paying that much attention to them
even though they are things that make an
impression you know
subconsciously about the character uh
but in the case of hedwig
they're just such such definitive pieces
that
that immediately you get a new piece of
the hedwig personality every time a
costume appears and i know he had like
41 costumes uh for hedwig to
to do in that film just for john cameron
mitchell
thousands of costumes in maybe but thank
you for saying that i mean i think the
thing
about costume design is its character
development and character illustration
so the great thing about hadwig is
people have a tendency to see it more
than once
kind of like rocky horror picture shows
so you know you can
your second time or maybe even your
third if you're lucky or fourth
you'll see different you know layers of
story in there not only with the
costumes but also with the wonderful
production design
by therese depray and you know i think
there's
the wonderful thing about john cameron
mitchell as a director
is he really um encouraged us
to create layers of story and
and and um you know whether it was
something hidden
or seen that would inform us in the
making of the movie
so yeah there are lots of things um the
story is
you know such a wonderful journey
that um you know you might need to see
it a second time to really get
some of the the high moments or 20
second time you know depends you know
some people
need a lot of time to soak it all in so
anyway
it's a movie that's fun to re-watch i
know that it's hard to
choose among your children with me when
you have 41 children in the
representing john's uh you know costumes
in this film
but at the same time uh i i literally
gasped when i saw the
the for a lack of a better term the the
hair
or probably better to call it the wig
dress that's the haircut we call the
hairdresser the hairdresser i mean is
either either way it fits into a nice uh
double entendre type of thing
i think that the fun thing about that is
you can just see the sheer joy
that he's having performing in that
terror
yes there's a fine line between joy and
terror as we all know and that's a dress
too that i think
the craftsmanship of that dress really
shows because
it moves in just a particular way and it
just
feels so organic and i'm sure that that
was uh
not the easiest thing to uh put together
and and make work
just just my own personal favorite there
oh thank you i think
my favorites too i mean you think about
it john cameron mitchell as the director
was directing every day in full makeup
wigs
and high heels so why not add a dress
made of a wig
that's too much so uh we have some
uh polaroids that in some if somebody
saw them laying on a table might just
you know kind of casually think they
were you know snapshots or whatever but
i'm assuming that they were actually
reference photos that you were taking
and uh maybe some of them were for fun
too i don't know
but uh they're really unique uh
uh images from that uh period of work so
let's take a let's do a little slideshow
of some of your polaroids
great yes so
one of the things um you know i miss
polaroid so much i i always have a
polaroid camera with me on set around
this time
and i'm al i i was just so marveled like
i said that
and john cameron mitchell not only was
starring as hedwig
but he was directing himself and um here
he is
checking the shot before he's in the
scene and full wig
makeup and costume and i was just
you know he popped up on the dolly to
check the shot before he ran
in front of the camera and i was in
constant of him and i just love this
shot
it's just uh made me laugh with the with
the chinese daily special behind him
this is from a fitting um this costume
became
pretty iconic because it was on the
poster for a while
and this is john without of course wig
and makeup yeah one of the things
usually in fittings it's always great
when um the actors are able to have the
wig on especially if it's a different
hair color
and the makeup but this was uh i think
one of those days where
you know john being the director was so
over scheduled
we did the fitting without the wig and
he's um you know plain having a good
time in the fitting
and i just thought it was such a great
kind of
costume in process photo
this is from the set from uh john
cameron rachel wearing that hairdresser
that we spoke about earlier
this is from the set of um wig in the
box which is kind of like
a video music video within the film it's
just
the one kind of magical reality fantasy
moment
and we actually shot this i was reminded
i think on our last
day of shooting and it was
we were doing it at twilight and our
production designer tries to praise such
a genius
had rigged this trailer wall so that it
would
fall down and there are these um stage
lights on the corner so here we are in
between
setups you can see a fan in the
background because it was hot as hell in
the summer in toronto shooting
and um john in high heels of course
taking a break patiently waiting for his
next setup
this is the you know iconic hedwig
costume this costume um
of this kind of repurposed denim kind of
romper
and this cape that mimics the berlin
wall
all the art was done by this incredible
artist miguel villalobos
hedwig the movie was based on an
off-broadway play in
new york and and in the play hedwig only
had one costume i didn't design the play
but um this was
the film version of that
kind of recycled denim costume that was
so famous in the off-broadway production
this is a scene when hedwig is
prostituting
on in the meatpacking district in new
york and tommy gnosis comes in
and picks her up this is an onset photo
that i took
um i was inspired by a fashion designer
friend of mine
jeremy scott who had done this
collection and this idea of the kind of
one leg trouser and so we did our head
wig version so
so john's wearing like that thigh-high
boot that he wore in the
wig in the box costume and what i would
say about the costumes in general
is they're kind of method costumes and
that every costume
ha i felt that that we created i had to
be in the head of hedwig of how
she would have created this for herself
um because she is a dyi character
a do-it-yourself uh person so
um so that's that's what this point
should kind of shows a little gold razor
blade
that you know there's a lot of humor and
um
kind of uh wink and a nod in a lot of
these costumes so
this is from the set this is uh
at the end of the song exquisite corpse
where
hedwig um really just i made this dress
out of plastic actually we had to make
multiples of them
uh and they were wrapped literally
plastic bags
and we sewed we we built up the plastic
so much that
i was able to sew trim on and i put
grommets in it
and this is a scene when um hedwig
has really come to a point
where she is tired of the
the artifice and
rips her dress and uh it's the crescendo
of the end of the film and ends up
leaving the stage
naked so this is the stripping away of
the
artifice of this you know and and gender
this is really an
interesting conversation now that we're
having culturally about
gender and this is really about hedwig
not subscribing to gender and just being
true
to who hedwig is aha
the hairdress so my partner in crime on
the hairdresser's i um
i enlisted genius uh hair design wig
designer and makeup artist
mike potter who created hedwig the
original wig and the makeup design
with john back in the clubs of new york
before it was an off-broadway show and
mike has been
part of hedwig's evolution from you know
the
clubs of new york to off-broadway to the
movie
and then we all were reunited on
broadway
um in a few years ago so
um mike potter i i enlisted his
expertise
once we sewed these kind of wig wig
wafts
they caught west they call him wes west
of hair
kind of like a a fringe curtain and
um we this was a saturday a day off
during shooting in our hotel room in
toronto and i think
john john ended up just crying in the
middle of this he was so tired
but um we were listening to loud music
and and giving the costume a haircut
this is a scene uh from set a polaroid
on set from the menzies fair
which is kind of a riff on the i guess
the lilith fair of the 90s
and actually this piece was designed
by this really wonderful independent
designer
fashion designer named grant
and he was generous enough to
loan this to me for the shooting of the
movie and i loved it for
its scale and volume and it's it's
oversized
so it's like a a top um you can't see
the rest of the costume but it was
perfect for the scene
and and um it was that was a beautiful
day
we were shooting so here we go so here's
a fitting where
john actually has kind of a stand-in wig
so we could get
a sense of you know what the hair would
look like with the costume this is a
costume
in progress that we made for sugar daddy
the
the song sugar daddy when hedwig
literally
gives a quote-unquote car wash to a
customer bilgewaters
so there's john in a very enthusiastic
uh pose uh during the fitting
this is a shot from the set uh
that i was lucky enough to get close in
on
of michael pitt and hedwig on set
um shooting a scene from the trailer
park and i particularly i love this
polaroid the lighting just worked out
beautifully and there's a
there's like a i love the expression on
john's face there's like
a poignancy to this this photo that
is uh so sweet and here's a
from the same session of them i guess i
busted them you know i caught a private
moment and then
maybe they were rehearsing in between
setups i can't remember probably
um and uh here they are you know
being we just had so much fun on the set
it was so great to see
these smiles and be reminded of that
time shooting together was really
special
here here we are again at the monitors
uh for that wig in the box scene
um john as the director of course in
full costume
with frank demarco you can see right
next to john who's the
dp the cinematographer and they're
talking i'm sure about the shot behind
john is miriam shore plays yet sock and
behind miriam
in white you see steven trask who's the
lyricist and
uh co-creator of hedwig and uh
i don't remember the other people are
unfortunately it's been 20 years but
uh crew members there so that is on set
you can see we have a
kind of pop-up over us i think it was
threatening rain that night a humid
toronto summer here
is a shot of john in between takes at
the
beginning of the song exquisite
exquisite corpse
in that plastic dress which was really
created
building up layers and layers of
basically plastic bags
and clear tape um and then
we put grommets and uh
i sewed in like a beaded fringe on the
bottom
and this is uh john's costume for
exquisite corpse of course
we saw in the other polaroid when he
rips it off
you know it's kind of the crescendo
of of exquisite corpse
um this is just like kind of an artistic
shot i
i did on set with the cape from
the opening costume from tear me down
um just john is um
so photogenic and is such a
brilliant actor let alone director
and a muse really for me i took a lot of
pictures of john on set
because i i he was just so beautiful as
hedwig and i was so
moved by his ability to seamlessly move
in front
and behind the camera it's incredible
here we are um in that sugar daddy
costume
um behind the camera probably getting a
wig
touch up as john always as people know
on set
you know actors with a lot of makeup
have to drink water with straws
and um just an in-between moment on the
set from shooting the
the car wash scene the um sugar daddy
scene
this might have been a continuity photo
where i was trying to
but maybe it was just an artistic shot
that wig always makes for such a great
frame on john's face so you can see the
costume close-up there's a
little rabbit fur pull on there and
lots of crystals i always say i was my
own sweatshop on this movie there are
only
two of us in our department sometimes
three
and so um it was actually a really
wonderful experience having just come
off a big studio film
to work on an independent film where i
was doing everything
and it really helped me kind of
recalibrate
how important it is sometimes we get
removed from the set
as costume designers since we're always
you know we're technically an offset
position
or we get removed from the making of a
costume
so this was is such a memorable film for
me because i was able to
kind of be involved in all aspects of
the
um costumes from creation to being on
set
and this is mike potter the genius wig
designer and
makeup artist who created hedwig's look
from day one
from the nightclubs of new york city to
off-broadway hedwig
to the film he was my partner
in um you know crime and
we were yeah the costume is really only
completed by the wig and makeup and we
really really worked
closely i don't think i've ever worked
so intimately
with another hair and makeup artist so
that was
really thrilling that we were able to
kind of create these looks
together with different wigs that's
mike again mike potter who played a
little guest role
as a prostitute in the meatpacking
district a male prostitute male drag
prostitute in the meat packing district
but and i think he's in
partial makeup there
and mike potter again um he
is uh modeling hedwig's
sunglasses that we see in the beginning
of the movie
he was my muse as well
and mike potter doing hair for one of
the
head heads which are hedwig's groupies
this is paul who is actually a long time
friend of
john cameron mitchell john had a lot of
his friends play different parts in the
movie it was a real family atmosphere
this is michael pitt who
in a fitting for tommy nosis one of his
performance
costumes and michael was incredible to
work with
another tommynosis costume fitting with
michael pitt
and another one i don't think that made
the cut
and this is a photo of michael pitt on
set
for that trailer park scene and um
i love the lighting now you know it's
just by chance by accident
that he's kind of out of focus and you
get kind of you can see the cables in
the
right corner of the set and then you can
see that kind of painted backdrop in the
background
so you really get a sense of like the
movie-making
aspect and and that's him as
young tommy before it becomes tommy
gnosis
and michael pitt um as tommynosis uh
i i i believe that's on set because
that's a costume t-shirt
i don't think it's a fitting um probably
uh in between takes and
um probably rehearsing guitar he did a
lot of rehearsing guitar
and there's michael as tommy knows this
with these fabulous
leather trousers we made for him kind of
as low as we could go
in that jim morrison um kind of
tradition
wanted these um leather pants to feel
like a second skin
and the way that frank marco was
shooting it was in very low light
there's a you know you also see hedwig
in this scene coming out of darkness
so uh very happy with the way it turned
out
well that was really fantastic ariane
thank you so much it is
great to feel like we were on the set
and at the same time
to be able to look at the detail on some
of these polaroids when you're watching
a film sometimes the costumes are so
busy moving around that you don't really
get to see and so this was a really
fun way to you know concentrate a little
bit more on your work and at the same
time
uh you know celebrate the the what was
actually going on
20 years ago as you were making the film
so thank you so much
thank you thank you so much for having
me
you